have been taking Ivermectin and Vendezol. Are they good for sensitizing the tumor cells during my
30-planned radiation sessions? This is the same person. This would be a complement to the weekly
chemo session that I have been that they have been doing for this purpose. Yes, you know, there's
some talk out there on the internet that Ivermectin and Vendezol help increase the
effective chemotherapy and or radiation and increase the benefit. I don't know if that data
how correct that data is, so I can't really speak to that or not. I can say that both Ivermectin
and Vendezol are not counter active to radiation and or chemotherapy. They're not
they're not antioxidant therapies. They're not oxidative therapies either, so they're not
complimentary in the sense that they're increasing the oxidative stress that chemotherapy and
radiation are producing. That's how radiation works. That's how chemotherapy works is that it's
creating a high degree of oxidative stress. That's what radiation does. So radiation to a healthy cell
could end up causing cancer because it's creating oxidative stress, but to a cancer cell
it could cause cell death because a cancer cell is already has a higher level of
resting oxidative stress near its lethal death limit. So it's sitting at a state,
its resting state is nearer of the threshold of lethal death of oxidative stress. So the
radiation and chemotherapy and almost every therapy that you're doing from my clinic is an oxidative
therapy. You're taking you know, protocell oxidative therapy, you're taking high dose,
curcumin, high dose, vitamin E, high dose, burberry, high dose, vitamin C. All those are oxidative.
So almost all the therapies that are done from a natural perspective to kill cancer cells are
oxidative because cancer cells are already sitting at a higher oxidative stress level and we're just
pushing and past that threshold of lethal death. That's how it works. So but I've
been back to the infant Mendezol though there's been multiple pathways that have suggested
its metabolic benefit for cancer. One of the key components that I believe is that it
upregulates the intrinsic apoptonic pathway by upregulating the P53 tumor suppressor genes.
So remember your tumor suppressor genes kick on and kill cancer cells when it senses
the cell going into rapid replication, quote, unquote cancer. So tumor suppressor genes will kick
on and activate the intrinsic apoptonic pathway to kill a cancer cell. I've erected infant Mendezol
help do that. That's one of the ways that curcumin and burberry'd work as well. They
upregulate the different tumor suppressor gene pathways. So it's not counter-tuitive to say that
could I take Iver back to the infant Mendezol while I'm doing radiation or while I'm doing chemo.
Of course you can, there's no there's no negatives of that. The only caveat that I'd say is you have
to make sure you're checking your liver markers because chemo is very toxic. Whereas like taking
high dose vitamin C or taking high dose curcumin or burberry or other things that I have you guys on
is not as non-toxic to healthy cells. And it will almost never cause irritation in your liver,
elevated your AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase. It spares healthy cells. That's the benefit of a
natural approach. That's a benefit of doing the right. It spares healthy cells. However,
that Mendezol and Iver back to our medicines. So as chemo therapy is a medicine, those are drugs.
They don't spare healthy cells and they can be toxic to your liver if you don't detoxify them well.
So you should be checking your liver markers and how you do that is getting a comprehensive
metabolic panel. So you can ask for a comprehensive metabolic panel. Typically if you're doing chemo,
they're doing blood every week. They're doing blood every time I go and do chemo. While they're only
doing a CBC. So they're only looking at your red blood cells and your white blood cells because chemo
is also going to destroy your white blood cell line. That's the negative about doing chemo. Whereas
most of the therapies that we're going to recommend don't do that. Even Iver back to the Mendezol
don't lower your white blood cell count. But it can damage your liver marker. So would you go
in to do chemo every two weeks or every week, whatever you're doing and you're getting a blood test.
If they're not doing a comprehensive metabolic profile, they're not looking at your liver marker.
So you have to ask for that sometimes. If you're doing Mendezol and Iver back to you, you should be
getting regular comprehensive metabolic profiles. If you're doing any chemo or radiation, you should
do that too. Unfortunately, a lot of oncologists don't order them. You're going to have to be wise and
up to ask for those.